بين اولى خطوات التاسيس لجامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده سوريا اليها بعد تجميد طويل
للعضويه ثمانيه عقود مرت فيها سوريا بتقلب
العلاقات مع الجامعه
تاريخيا سوريا كانت من اوائل الدول التي
شاركت بتمثيل قوي في الجامعه العربيه بعد
دعوه مصطفى النحاس رئيس الوزراء المصري
لنظيره السوري جميل مردنبك الى القاهره
لمناقشه انشاء تحالف عربي عام
1944 وتكون سوريا ضمن الدول السبع الموقعه
البروتوكول الاسكندريه
قمه الجامعه عام
1967 في الخرطوم وحربي يونيو حيث خسرت
سوريا مناطق ابرزها الجولان في الحرب مع
اسرائيل وسميت بقمه اللات ثلاث لا صلح لا
تفاوض ولا اعتراف باسرائيل شاركت فيها
كافه الدول العربيه باستثناء سوريا التي
دعت الى حرب تحرير شعبيه
بيان ختامي صدر عن القمه العربيه في
نوفمبر
1973 في الجزائر التي انعقدت بمبادره
سوريه مصريه يقضي بتقديم الدعم المالي
والعسكري لسوريا ومصر بعد شنهما حرب
اكتوبر على اسرائيل لاسترداد الاراضي التي
خسيرتها في حرب 1967
قمه مايو 1990 في بغداد غابت عنها سوريا
اثر الخلافات السياسيه بين دمشق وبغداد
لكنها عادت للحضور الى القمه الطارئه في
اغسطس من نفس العام في القاهره على خلفيه
غزو العراق للكويت لتدين الحرب وتتضامن مع
الدول الخليج في المطالبه باخراج القوات
العراقيه من الكويت
اما اخر القمم التي برز فيها اسم سوريا
كانت في نوفمبر 2011 بعد ان اجمع القاده
العرب على تجميد عضويه دمشق على خلفيه رد
فعلها على الحراك الشعبي في البلاد اذا
عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات